[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
alors que les bombardements russes
continuent les villes ukrainiennes sont
plongées dans le noir les Ukrainiens
sont privés d'eau d'électricité de
chauffage de services de santé 47 pays
et 22 organisations ou institutions
financières se sont réunis à Paris pour
financer la résilience et la
reconstruction du pays un milliard
d'euros de dons ont été promis à l'issue
de cette conférence la première partie
c'est focalisée sur l'aide d'urgence la
seconde sur la reconstruction de
l'Ukraine il y a bien eu d'autres
conférences à Lugano à Varsovie ou
encore à Berlin mais depuis les Russes
ciblent les infrastructures civiles et
non plus militaires les dégâts sur les
réseaux énergétiques sont donc énormes
alors comment aider les Ukrainiens à
passer l'hiver à quoi vont servir les 1
milliard d'euros de promesses de dons
comment aider aussi à reconstruire
l'Ukraine à plus long terme peut-on
évoquer la reconstruction d'un pays sans
parler d'un plan de paix et bien on va
poser ces questions à nos invités le
plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés Oxana
microfanova bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous ce soir docteur en sciences
politiques enseignante chercheuse à
l'INALCO cherche seniors également à
l'Institut d'histoire mondiale de
l'Académie nationale des sciences du
crâne acquief merci d'être avec nous
dans le débat Pauline golard bonsoir
Pauline journaliste à France 24 vous
revenez toujours du crâne et on va voir
votre reportage dans cette édition et
puis évidemment vous allez nous raconter
un petit peu ce que vous avez vu sur
place Oleg coptef bonsoir historien
géographe professeur de géopolitique à
l'américaine University of Perses et on
attend Frédéric Joly porte parole du
Comité international de la Croix-Rouge
en France qui est coincé manifestement
dans les embouteillages en Ukraine 40%
des infrastructures énergétiques ont été
détruites ces deux derniers mois le pays
dépend à 50% du nucléaire pour sa
production d'électricité un milliard
d'euros de dons ont été promis à l'issue
de la conférence on fait le point et on
en discute ensuite
le président ukrainien réclamait 800
millions d'euros pour permettre à son
peuple de passer l'hiver les donateurs
présents lors de la conférence de
solidarité avec l'Ukraine organisé ce
mardi à Paris ont vu plus grand en fait
je suis heureuse de pouvoir vous
annoncer que nous dépassons ce chiffre
et que nous sommes plus proches du
milliard d'euros près de la moitié de la
somme sera consacrée à l'énergie 25
millions d'euros pour l'eau 38 pour
l'alimentation 17 millions pour la santé
22 millions pour les transports
493 millions seront encore à distribuer
le principal défi du moment répondre aux
besoins immédiats des Ukrainiens qui
manque de tout à commencer par un
approvisionnement en électricité chaque
jour plusieurs millions d'entre eux sont
déconnectés du réseau en raison des
frappes russes qui endommagent les
installations
au moins un milliard et demi d'euros
sont nécessaires rien que pour les
premières réparations des installations
énergétiques ukrainiennes détruite par
les frappes russes
voilà pourquoi les générateurs et les
sources d'alimentation sans interruption
sont devenues aussi nécessaires en
Ukraine que les véhicules blindés les
gilets par balles
avec un objet Emmanuel Macron à lui
annoncé une nouvelle aide de 48,5
millions d'euros et la livraison de 63
nouveaux générateurs de haute puissance
et plusieurs transformateurs des moyens
qui selon les pays donateurs devraient
permettre à l'Ukraine de tenir jusqu'à
la mi-mars environ et d'éviter notamment
un éventuel blackout dans le pays
donc vous êtes l'Ukrainienne du plateau
vous venez de Kiev vous habitez en
France depuis un moment votre réaction à
cette annonce est-ce que c'est un
milliard de promesses de dons
correspondent aux besoins des Ukrainiens
aujourd'hui je pense que donner un
chiffre exact c'est très difficile et
même c'est pas possible tout simplement
parce que on ne peut pas prévoir combien
de frappes on peut avoir aussi dans
l'avenir proche et donc combien de
centrales on va détruire encore mais je
pense que cette conférence est très
importante et éventuellement Emmanuel
Macron il a fait un bon analyse de
tactique rousse donc elle vient
totalement elle a bien compris de gens
en septembre en octobre qu'est-ce que ça
va donner du coup le top il frappe les
infrastructures énergétiques déjà
exactement et donc voilà pourquoi le
président de la France a organisé cette
conférence pour essayer de résoudre ce
problème mais bien sûr une coopération
avec ses partenaires parce que le défi
c'est immense et la France ne peut pas
aider le crâne parce que vraiment
beaucoup de
la plateforme en question bien sûr la
plateforme va aider il faut comprendre
quand on parle de reconstruction de
reconstruction de l'Ukraine il faut
diviser en deux parties il faut bien
prendre en compte qu'il y a maintenant
la reconstruction d'urgence c'est pas le
reconstruction de demain mais il y a des
territoires libérés tout simplement
aussi il y a des territoires libérés on
a parlé déjà des garçons pendant le
dernier débat moi aussi il y a l'est de
l'Ukraine et donc quand notre territoire
est libéré il y a de besoin d'urgence
tout simplement alloué justement c'était
territoire libéré l'eau par exemple il
faut provisé l'eau potable il faut
essayer ramener des médicaments et même
les hôpitaux doivent fonctionner même si
les hôpitaux sont détruits les maladies
ne peuvent pas attendre il faut faire
les opérations en urgence et pour tout
ça même on a besoin aussi de générateur
et transformateur tout simplement pour
éclairer au mois de blocs où il y a
réanimation et on fait des opérations
c'est une conférence comme celle-ci
est-ce qu'elle correspond effectivement
besoin sur place
certainement
très honnêtement je ne sais quoi
rajouter parce que c'est un ami de la
fin va dit l'essentiel je pense et vous
vous allez en revenant fraîche de du
Crès certainement complété
415 millions à louer au secteur de
l'énergie 25 millions pour l'eau 38
millions pour l'alimentation 17 millions
pour la santé 22 millions pour les
transports donc là c'est vrai que tout
est tout de même très cadré carré est-ce
que ça va arriver de cette manière là en
Ukraine c'est la question là ça c'est
une bonne question il faudra tout de
même ici en Europe ou en Occident avoir
tout de même des institutions qui
surveillent ça de près
il ne faut pas que
que de l'argent ou des produits
disparaissent soudains qu'on les on les
retrouve sur le marché noir ou autre on
a vu ça juste après l'effondrement du
communisme par exemple moi je voyais ça
dans les rues des petits marchands qui
vendaient ouvertement des des de la
nourriture marquée gum-pom et aide
humanitaire vous voyez donc il faudra
surveiller ça de de très près et il n'y
a pas que ça il faut aussi il faut pas
alors bon déjà il y a un problème c'est
et Madame mitroffen très bien dit
les bombardements vont continuer ils
vont peut-être même aller de plus belle
plus on va aider l'Ukraine
financièrement ou matériellement plus il
y aura de bombardements parce que le le
but de ce type de de combat à présent de
cette stratégie c'est une stratégie à la
gare de 14 c'est-à-dire c'est le premier
qui cède qui paye c'est une guerre
vraiment d'usure et ça c'est vraiment
sur ce les pour les Ukrainiens c'est une
guerre de libération du territoire mais
pour les Russes pour le moment c'est une
guerre d'usure et plus on va aider les
Ukrainiens faut s'attendre à des
destructions de plus en plus massive
malheureusement donc il va falloir
prévoir cela et se préparer à cela
maintenant évidemment une conférence
comme aujourd'hui vaut mieux ça que que
de rester assis à ne rien faire et on
accueille Frédéric Joly qui vient de
s'installer bonsoir porte-parole du
Comité international de la Croix-Rouge
justement on parlait de cette conférence
de ce milliard d'euros de promesses de
dons vous connaissez bien les problèmes
d'infrastructures sur place vous la
Croix-Rouge puisque vous travaillez dans
les hôpitaux est-ce qu'effectivement
parler de médicaments les problèmes sont
énormes j'imagine il y a pas de
chauffage il y a pas d'électricité
comment fait-on lorsque on a des
prisonniers pardon lorsqu'on a dit c'est
important aussi
bah écoutez oui on est on est face à des
besoins colossaux impliquant des des
millions de personnes qui sont
littéralement soit sous perfusion
humanitaires quand on peut y aller c'est
vrai que c'est des bruits par elle-même
dans des conditions tout à fait
épouvantables ça pose aussi la question
de la guerre en ville qui a des impacts
colossaux sur les populations civile ça
pose le problème de respect des
infrastructures nécessaires à la survie
des civils alors là il y a une nouvelle
séquence qui s'ouvre avec l'hiver mais
depuis des mois la population se
retrouvait
sans sans eau potable si on prend
mikolaïve par exemple la nouvelle
présidente du CICR était ce weekend à
mi-colaïves et elle a pu à la fois
s'entretenir avec avec la population et
aussi voir le travail du CICR pour
essayer de remettre en oeuvre des
adductions d'eau ou alors de de
d'organiser des norias de de
camions-citerne de flotte ou encore de
disposer avec la Croix Rouge ukrainienne
avec les autorités de la ville et bien
des réservoirs suffisamment nombreux
pour que la population puisse avoir
accès l'arrivée de l'hiver va
incontestablement compliquer la
situation et rendre encore plus
vulnérable des populations qu'il était
déjà et que pour nous c'est Isère c'est
l'accès aux soins qui demeure la
priorité le respect des infrastructures
nécessaires à la survie des populations
civiles et aussi faire en sorte et là de
tous les côtés et bien que l'accès
humanitaire soit garantie par les
parties au conflit c'est-à-dire que l'on
puisse passer des lignes de front et
pouvoir acheminer l'aide nécessaire
c'est le cas aujourd'hui ou pas
on peut jamais généraliser vous avez
c'est on n'a pas de boule de cristal on
essaye de suivre l'évolution même du
conflit et qui a des endroits où ça
passe des embrouilles ça ne passe pas
les négociations c'est pas la même
temporalité il faut beaucoup plus de
temps à négocier pour avoir le
Greenlight et l'accès qui va nous
permettre de passer tel ou tel
zone de enfin ligne de front donc le
travail est fait dans les conditions que
l'on sait c'est pas l'humanitaire qui va
régler le problème de ce conflit armé
internationalitaire est vraiment
politique alors on parle de
reconstruction c'est bien tout ce qui
peut tendre à améliorer la situation
c'est bien mais en attendant il faut que
l'humanitaire
la Croix Rouge ukrainienne le CICR aussi
plein d'autres organisations puissent
continuer à faire ce qu'elles font déjà
depuis des mois parce que
malheureusement parler de reconstruction
c'est formidable mais là l'hiver et il
est là il est maintenant là vous qui
revenez tout juste du crâne c'est un peu
ce que vous avez vu vous êtes allé
d'ailleurs à Mikola Frédéric joli en
parler à l'instant vous êtes allés
également à Odessa les infrastructures
sont détruites énergétiques surtout il y
a urgence sur place est-ce que vous avez
constaté
c'est une certitude il y a vraiment
urgence alors ce qui est ce qui est
quand même fou et c'est ce qu'on a vu à
chaque fois c'est cette détermination
des Ukrainiens cette résilience ils sont
ils sont prêts ils sont déterminés ils
sont là ils nous ont dit hein il
lâcheront rien malgré les conditions
malgré ce qui se passe c'est franchement
la plupart des Ukrainiens avec qui on a
parlé ils étaient vraiment dans cet état
d'esprit là et ce qui est quand même
assez incroyable parce qu'en effet ils
vivent dans des conditions très et on
l'a vu en effet à mikolaïve par exemple
c'est vrai que vous ouvrez votre robinet
quand vous avez de l'eau qui arrive et
bien c'est de l'eau salée qui arrive
parce que par exemple ils ont dû
connecter les réseaux à l'estuaire pour
essayer d'acheminer de l'eau le problème
c'est que les pompes ont été détruites
que ils les ont réparé mais qu'ils n'ont
pas d'électricité donc ils peuvent pas
pelo pour la pour la dessaler et on se
retrouve en effet dans un cercle vicieux
et qui a été ce qui nous a été dit aussi
quand on était à zapporja quand on était
à Herson en fait c'est on répare on fait
on fait ce qu'on peut on fait de la
bidouille et puis le problème c'est
qu'après il retape on a nous on est à
nouveau frappé et on se retrouve encore
dans une problématique de réparation et
donc voilà c'était tout ça en plein
hiver avec un hiver qui sera de plus en
plus rude bien sûr puisque avec nous le
chauffage les villes qui à 16h 16h30 les
grandes villes sont je parle des grandes
villes parce que le reste c'est dans le
noir très rapidement et sont
complètement plongés dans le noir il y a
pas de feuilles il y a des accidents de
voiture parce que les gens font pas
attention ils voient pas les piétons on
a assisté d'ailleurs à un accident de
voiture quand on y était parce que parce
que voilà parce que les gens en fait ne
voient pas ce qui se passe et il fait
nuit et puis assez coupure d'électricité
alternative qui font que les gens se
retrouvent vite dans le froid chez eux
et bah pareil il y a des il trouve des
systèmes des aussi parfois pour essayer
de se chauffer notamment une professeure
qu'on a pu rencontrer qui en fait chez
elle mettait sur la gazinière en fait
ils mettaient des pierres qui permettait
en fait de faire une espèce de
condensation de chaleur et qui
permettait de chauffer leur cuisine par
exemple c'est voilà c'était on est
arrivé ils nous ont montré ça ils
faisaient bon juste dans la cuisine mais
au moins ils nous ont dit bah c'est la
seule solution qu'on a trouvé pour
l'instant pour se chauffer vu que là on
a pas d'électricité qu'on a pas d'eau
système D vous avez suivi des
électriciens Pauline qui travaille eux
en continu dans des conditions
extrêmement compliquées pour rétablir
justement le réseau électrique quand ils
peuvent on va regarder votre portage
réparer des centaines et des centaines
de kilomètres de câbles électriques
depuis la libération des mains des
Russes début novembre des villages à
l'est de mikolaïves ces techniciens
travaillent sans relâche
tout autour d'eux le terrain est miné
ils prennent des risques considérables
mais ils sont plus motivés que jamais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
60% des câbles sont endommagés voilà
pourquoi nous avons tant de travail à
faire dans l'urgence pour rétablir le
réseau électrique nous travaillons petit
bout par petit bout notre but est que
les gens vivent à nouveau dans des
conditions normales
un travail de fourmi auquel s'ajoutent
les conditions météorologiques la pluie
ne leur laisse aucun répit régulièrement
leurs camions sans bourbe
l'hiver arrive les températures baisses
alors les électriciens tentent de
réparer le plus vite possible le Réseau
ici 90% des foyers n'ont pas
d'électricité pour la plupart depuis 9
mois
depuis octobre les Russes s'acharnent à
bombardé les infrastructures
énergétiques ukrainiennes mais aussi les
dépôts de matériel une grande partie des
camions de la compagnie régionale
d'électricité de mikolave a été détruite
par un obus des dégâts étaient déjà
nombreux avant leur départ après 9 mois
d'occupation les Russes ont tout saccagé
pictures
ce sont des photos prises le premier
jour après l'occupation nos bureaux
servaient de base aux troupes
d'occupation russes et vous pouvez voir
ce que les rues sont les sites
très fier de ces équipes Vadim nous
confie être bien conscient que les
efforts à fournir seront encore nombreux
de l'électricité dans la ville dans les
villages mais après la guerre nous
devrons complètement rebâtir le réseau
parce que pour le moment notre travail
consiste à fournir à ces villages de
l'électricité c'est du temporaire après
nous reconstruirons tout et nous aurons
besoin de beaucoup d'argent
le coup estimé de la reconstruction pour
l'ensemble du pays toute infrastructure
confondues est impressionnant entre 500
et 600 milliards d'euros selon la Banque
mondiale et ce chiffre n'est que
provisoire
[Applaudissements]
donc une réaction peut-être à ce qu'on
vient de voir bon c'est sûr que ce qui a
changé depuis quelques mois ce sont les
bombardements des Russes et ils savent
où bombarder c'est un petit peu ce qu'on
voit dans le reportage de Pauline
bien sûr moi je pense que
malheureusement cette situation ne te
preview parce que je me rappelle notre
débat en septembre déjà je dis qui est
bombardé parce que c'est très simple à
réaliser c'est c'est très simple pour
les Russes comment ils n'arrivent pas à
faire quelque chose ou pas militaire
donc tout simplement le population c'est
une cible qui est plus simple et bien
sûr ils en ont entendu aussi ont pu les
vers l'arrivée des Verts mais il y a
aussi l'autre danseur que se pose suite
à ce bombardement c'est les questions
quand même grave de chauffage et il
s'agit exactement de grandes villes où
la plupart des populations n'habite dans
de grandes blocs et le situation ne
suivante si on imagine le situations qui
est il y a par exemple - Centre le
température ce manque au mois 10 c'est
que normal pour l'Ukraine ensuite
bombardement le système de circulation
de l'eau dans le tube et arrêtez dans ce
cas là après 24 heures il faut de faire
descendre de leur donc le seul radiateur
sans l'eau et remettre ce sera
impossible en possible avant le
printemps donc ce lieu au système de
chauffage en Ukraine c'est c'est grâce
aux circulations de l'eau chaude donc
qu'est-ce qu'on peut obtenir comme comme
le citation - 10 - 15 - 20 il n'a pas de
chauffage dans de grandes blocs et dans
le blog bien sûr on ne peut pas ramener
du bois je fais par du bois
pollinisateur il le redoutent cet hiver
parce que là c'est le début de l'hiver
on va dire en Ukraine oui c'est le début
de l'hiver mais bon les températures ont
par exemple des apora on est tombé
jusqu'à -15 quand on était en reportage
là-bas alors ce qui a été créé aussi et
ce qui a mis volody mars qui en place
c'est les points d'invincibilité il a
appelé ça c'est une forme de de
résistance aussi pour montrer la
résistance des Ukrainiens et c'est pas
un invincibilité on vu par exemple un à
rerson donc c'est des ce sont des tentes
dans lesquelles vous avez à l'extérieur
des générateurs qui permettent de
fournir de l'électricité de internet
aussi également donc on peut venir se
réchauffer boire une petite tasse de
café un boisson chaude on peut venir sur
tout charger son portable pour pouvoir
communiquer et puis avoir accès à
Internet parce que c'est pareil dès que
l'électrique dès qu'il y a plus
d'électricité souvent le réseau aussi
est coupé et on peut plus nous s'y
retrouver dans des situations où bah on
essayait de d'être en direct avec vous
et on y arrivait pas parce que tout d'un
coup il y a plus de réseau donc voit vos
images
ça c'est tout à fait ça ce sont les
points d'invincibilité et puis c'est
aussi l'occasion faut le dire en fait
parce qu'il y a plein de plein
d'Ukrainiens qui restent essentiellement
chez eux parce que rerson a été occupé
pendant 9 mois mais là aujourd'hui il se
retrouve libre mais il reste chez eux
parce qu'ils ont peur des bombardements
puisque les Russes maintenant ce sont de
l'autre côté du niep et il tape tous les
jours et frappe tous les jours rerson
donc c'est aussi un petit moment ils
nous ont dit aussi un petit moment de
convivialité si je puis dire oui ils
peuvent se retrouver ils peuvent
discuter un un petit peu en trop entre
eux et voilà avoir ce petit ce petit
moment ensemble
parce que c'est quand même très très
très compliqué
permettre très brièvement je crois que
ce qui est beaucoup plus urgent que de
reconstruire des usines entières c'est
dont ils ont réellement besoin et
notamment dans les les blocs
d'appartements dont vous avez parlé
c'est des générations c'est ça c'est je
crois que la priorité c'est ça c'est
dégénérateurs dégénérateurs des
générateurs et d'ailleurs à Odessa quand
vous êtes à Odessa en fait vous la vie
et le son de la ville c'est rythmé au
son des générateurs vous avez des
générateurs à peu près tous les 100
mètres tous les mètres
déjà pas mal mais
il y a malheureusement des biocrates qui
alors ça peut-être
il y a des associations humanitaires
notamment je vais faire un peu de
publicité pour
l'aefu qui est une association pour les
orphelins d'Ukraine qui est tout un
réseau de d'associations de ce type en
fédération d'associations pour les
orphelins d'Ukraine en France et bon ils
essayent d'envoyer des générateurs il y
en a qui disparaissent alors là aussi il
faut là je crois que c'est prévu au sein
de la Conférence d'ailleurs la France
générateur Frédéric Joly il y a
également la problématique des mines me
semble-t-il ça c'est ça remonte pas mal
du côté du Comité international de la
Croix-Rousse c'est-à-dire on sort des
hôpitaux effectivement on risque de
tomber sur des mines ça ça fait partie
aussi des vrais problèmes
qu'elles doivent faire face les
Ukrainiens tout ce qui a très au sommet
d'antipersonnel qui continue dans
quelques endroits de la planète à être
posé mais aussi des munitions d'un
exposé donc une pollution finalement
fait que les gens pour aller chercher du
bois vont peut-être y réfléchir à deux
fois tout simplement parce que il y a le
risque est tant que cette menace perdure
et bien tout est ralenti on voit dans
d'autres contextes si on prend la Syrie
si on prend l'Irak si on prend le Yémen
enfin ou il y a ses débris non explosé
qui font que même après je dis pas la du
conflit donc quand les hostilités sont
vraiment de bas niveau et bien la guerre
continue tout simplement parce que les
gens sont coincés et ne peuvent pas
retourner dans leur champ ne peuvent pas
laisser leurs gamins sortir et que donc
cette problème de pollution ça devra
aussi faire partie de la reconstruction
on peut pas imaginer compte tenu de
l'intensité des combats de la longueur
de front de du nombre d'échanges de
munitions et bien que l'on puisse se
pérenniser pour les populations civiles
une situation sans que ne véritable
financement du déminage et de cette
dépollution ne soit ne soit envisagées
il y en a il y en a vraiment partout
enfin quand on a fait notre reportage là
sur avec les électriciens donc c'est ce
qu'on disait on voit ces petits rubans
c'est pour signaler donc tous les
endroits où il y a des mines et la
région donc qui était donc occupé il y a
encore quelques semaines et qui a été
libéré et vraiment vous voyez on peut
prendre que certaines routes il y a des
rubans partout partout des mines tout
est minée
continue de travailler énormément dans
le don de base uniquement sur le
mindowarness c'est à dire signaler aux
populations parce que tout le don basse
et jonché de débris ou de mines et donc
qui met nécessairement sous perfusion la
population aussi ville et l'expose à
très grand risque Oxana également le
pays dépend à 50 % du nucléaire j'ai vu
pour sa production d'électricité alors
là aussi il y a Emmanuel Macron affirmé
donc des discussions étaient en cours
pour fixer des modalités de retrait des
armes lourdes autour de la centrale de
zaporigia il y a également l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique qui
manifestement en tout cas Raphaël
grossit son son patron a dit que il
allait mettre en place un accord pour
impliquer là la partie russe enfin il
faut qu'il y ait des négociations autour
de cette centrale nucléaire et autour du
nucléaire de manière générale pour
sécuriser ces endroits mais bien sûr
absolument parce que d'abord il s'agit
de sécurité tout simplement planétaire
parce que on sait très bien qu'est-ce
que c'est le danger nucléaire avec
Tchernobyl exactement et surtout les
Français connaissent très bien parce que
c'est qui ont construit sarcophage donc
d'abord
de l'énergie oui mais le problème qui
est le rousse sont bien conscients de ça
et il me semble que pendant le dernier
album c'est exactement les centrales
nucléaires suite à tout ça ils étaient
arrêtés et voilà pourquoi c'était assez
problématique pour le réseau en
énergétique ukrainien si les Russes à
faire arrêter tous les centrales
nucléaires d'Ukraine c'est le manque le
manque d'énergétique sera vraiment très
aimante est-ce que on arrive résoudre ce
problème on espère mais c'est un peu
difficile de prévoir évidemment sa
moniteur de l'ensemble de l'électricité
l'ensemble de l'énergie en Ukraine
puisque c'est 50% les cops que l'énergie
l'électricité vient de l'électricité
vient de des centrales nucléaires
oui donc c'est terrible et sauf que en
fait l'armée russe aussi en profite
parce que si vous voulez il se servent
pas de bouclier humain ils accusent les
Ukrainiens de servir de boucliers
humains enfin quand on bombarde
absolument tout je vois pas où on
pourrait ne pas avoir des boucliers
humains puisque tout le monde est une
cible mais eux ils se servent en fait de
il se servent de des centrales
nucléaires comme bouclier atomique en
fait alors si effectivement il y a des
armes lourdes derrière ou juste à côté
des centrales nucléaires
que nous pensons nous pensons tous
évidemment soit on se laisse tirer
dessus par par ces armes lourdes on
essaye de
on essaye de les éliminer et évidemment
il y a un risque énorme de toucher la
centrale nucléaire et en fait l'armée
russe et le Kremlin en profite pour
lever les bras aussi
regarder ces méchants Ukrainiens ils
vont provoquer une une catastrophe
nucléaire c'est
comprendre sans comprendre ce que c'est
complètement suicidaire parce que ça
fait longtemps qu'on dit si on protège
pas les centrales nucléaires c'est la
Russie qui va qui va subir surtout les
les conséquences atomiques puisque les
vents soufflent surtout d'est de d'Ouest
en Est vers la Russie sauf que tout est
suicidaire dans cette guerre de toute
manière en de le le
avoir lancé cette guerre était
suicidaire et puis pensons à Saddam
Hussein
pendant la première guerre du golf qui a
fait brûler toutes les
toutes les
tous les puits de pétrole coétiens c'est
surtout le l'Irak qui a souffert de ses
épouvantables
Poutine peut en faire autant pourquoi
quand on devient désespéré on fait
on peut faire complètement irrationnelle
nucléaire justement les Ukrainiens que
vous avez rencontrés sur place parce que
effectivement l'électricité elle vient
beaucoup de ces centrales oui alors on
en a en effet discuté avec eux et aussi
de de cette peur parce qu'il y a
énormément de de personnes qui vivaient
à enregard qui ont fui et Neruda donc
qui est la ville qui se situe vraiment
juste à côté de la centrale et où il
nous a pas déjà par des travailleurs et
en fait c'est alors c'est vrai qu'on
appelle la centrale la centrale de
zapporica mais c'est vrai que si on voit
sur alors là on voit pas sur la carte
mais c'est vrai que ça pourrait déjà se
trouve en fait la ville se trouve à côté
et les gens qui les gens donnèrent
fuient vers zapporica et eux en tout cas
les témoignages donc on a pu recueillir
nous ont dit en tout cas les anciens
travailleurs qui ont fui nous ont dit
qu'ils avaient vu en effet des des
camions arrivés avec des camions bâchés
qu'ils y en a certains ils nous ont ils
nous ont dit aussi qu'ils avaient vu des
soldats russes tirés aux environs de la
centrale et nous ont dit qu'ils avaient
en effet peur de ce qui pouvait arriver
et que les Russes se servaient aussi de
pas pour tirer sur nico-paul qui se
trouve juste en face ce qui est donc une
ville qui est toujours
ukrainienne et en fait les Ukrainiens
eux nous disent ben nous on peut on peut
pas riposter donc si on répond on tirait
sur la centrale et pourrait y avoir de
gros problèmes donc les Russes aussi
profitent de cette situation pour
pouvoir tirer sur nico-paul qui en fait
est une ville qui se retrouve sous le
feu des bombes nuitées jour on s'y est
rendu c'est c'est tous les habitants en
tout cas ceux qui restent sont assez
désespérés par cette situation et sont
choqués et on a d'ailleurs parlé avec
une vieille dame qui nous a dit qu'elle
a 83 ans elle a Parkinson elle nous a
dit mais je comprends pas on est censé
être frère et sœur à la base on est que
je comprends pas ce qui s'est passé elle
m'a dit elle nous a dit jamais je
comprendrais jamais je pourrais leur
pardonner ce qui s'est passé de toute
façon moi je suis je peux rien faire
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je fasse
vous voulez que j'aille donc je suis
obligé de rester là Oxana parce que
c'est vrai que maintenant il y a aussi
la problématique encore de la fuite d'un
certain nombre d'ukrainien qui de
nouveau réfugiés qui pourraient
justement être obligé de quitter
certaines villes Pauline vous me disiez
d'ailleurs que il les encouragent
parfois les autorités des différentes
villes à partir parce que justement pas
de chauffage pas d'électricité l'hiver
de plus en plus rude vous avez ce type
d'informations vous sur justement des
Ukrainiens qui seraient prêts à quitter
l'Ukraine oui tout simplement par
exemple le mode qui et là exprimé très
clairement sur le ce sujet il a donné
des conseils par exemple si on peut voir
les situations de block out et donc il
n'a pas l'argile du tout il faut bien
prendre en compte que quand même il y a
des gens de gens faibles par exemple il
y a deux enfants il y a des personnes
handicapées il y a des personnes malades
et de personnes âgées et donc du coup
ils donnent le conseil si c'est possible
pour des personnes qui sont fragiles
partir vous pouvez partir où mais partir
où et comment
vous êtes fragile sans différents si il
y a quelqu'un de la famille ou des amis
qui habitent par exemple dans le secteur
dans la maison dans la
et pour pour des autres personnes c'est
peut-être même d'essayer de trouver la
solution mais ce ne sera pas possible
d'informations qui vous remontent
justement de la Croix-Rouge sur place
d'un certain nombre de personnes qui
essayent de quitter leur ville leur
village certains de l'ukrainiens
j'imagine que depuis des mois
la question de base d'énormément de gens
c'est savoir si on part ou si on reste
il y a ceux qui ont choisi de rester ou
qui n'ont pas pu faire autrement vous
souligner les handicapés les malades les
dialysés un exemple parmi d'autres
comment on fait quand l'hôpital
fonctionne mal ou quand il y a une
rupture d'alimentation de de de
des produits du plasma etc les médecins
eux restent oui mais enfin je crois
autour des tables d'opération il y a
effectivement des situations critiques
mais enfin une fois de plus je pense que
on parle beaucoup de résilience c'est un
mot qui est très employé mais dans tous
les conflits armés dans tous les
endroits de la planète on voit qu'avant
tous les gens se débrouillent ou font ce
qu'ils peuvent par eux-mêmes et que
l'humanitaire si le droit international
humanitaire est respecté c'est à dire si
les humanitaires ont l'accès aux
populations aux victimes et bien on peut
apporter une réponse mais qui sera de
toute façon toujours toujours
insuffisante donc ça ça dépend d'accord
politique c'est absolument c'est les
politiques qui qui règle les crises
c'est pas l'humanitaire fait ce qu'il
peut parce que c'est intéressant c'est
que la deuxième partie de cette
conférence de Paris était consacrée
justement à la reconstruction de
l'Ukraine il y avait 500 entreprises
françaises des entreprises du CAC 40
mais aussi des startups qui étaient
conviées manifestement à certains
membres de contrats étaient signés Oxana
est-ce que c'est à peu prématuré de
parler de reconstruction finalement
c'est très politiques de parler de
reconstruction d'Ukraine d'abord je
voudrais vous rappeler le fait que juste
avant la guerre on a eu la période que
je définis comme la fenêtre de se porter
n'était dans la coopération économique
avec la France il faut bien prendre en
compte que cette guerre c'est aussi
c'est la guerre contre la coopération
économique entre la France et l'Ukraine
tout simplement parce que dans l'année
20 c'est un ministre de l'Économie Bruno
Le Maire qui a réveillé et qui a signé
plein de traités moi aussi événement qui
était très important Medef le
représentants de médailles
je voudrais vous rappeler quelque chose
très important et donc le président de
Medef arrive en Ukraine et c'est le
signe très important pour tout le monde
qui le pays est stable qui est en
Afrique
est-ce que ça sous-entend pas une
logique de paix quand on parle de
reconstruction
donc tout a changé et bien sûr c'était
pas la faute ni le français ni le
ukrainien donc qu'est-ce que c'est la
reconstruction je vous propose quand
même bien diviser bien comprendre qu'il
y a quelque chose comme la
reconstruction d'urgence mais tout
simplement par exemple les ponts par
exemple les ponts il y a le pont qu'il
faut construire en
urgence par exemple pour pour les
humanitaires tout simplement pour avoir
d'approvisionnement l'exemple très
concret par exemple
matière française qui a déjà construit
quelques ponts par exemple
ukrainiens ont donné les mesures très
exemples donc les
Ukrainiens se projettent déjà ils sont
déjà dans une construction
reconstruction du pays il faut
construire le pont maintenant tout
simplement pour approvisionner le pont
ensuite ça se pose par exemple les
questions de quand même il faut
construire par exemple de logement
maintenant parce que il y a des déplacer
intérieures il faut le gel maintenant
c'est pas demain c'est l'hiver ils sont
de place et donc par exemple il y a
aussi l'exemple très concrète à au
stomae il y a l'entreprise française qui
s'appelle Nero qui va reconstruire
quelques immeubles une école et aussi
une crèche ce qui est très intéressante
cette entreprise utilise les
technologies nouvelles et c'est
impossibilité de reconstruire vite parce
que cette entreprise va apprendre des
déchets de bâtiments et après l'analyse
dans le borotoir utilisant ces déchets
il y a les constructions des immeubles
aussi cette entreprise
la paille donc on est on est dans la
reconstruction l'heure est déjà la
reconstruction c'est ce que vous dites
maintenant mais bien sûr on prévoit le
reconstruction à l'avenir par exemple
les rails pour le chemin de fer aussi
par exemple ça ça veut dire qu'il faudra
qu'il est la paix quand même à un moment
donné au lait comme ça quand on parle de
reconstruction de rail pour l'avenir
c'est pas ne dépendent pas
nécessairement de l'autre et pour pour
soutenir madame mitrafan
rappelez-vous de la deuxième guerre
mondiale on commence à reconstruire les
villes bombardées de Normandie où il n'y
a plus rien que un peu comme Mario Paul
en ce moment on commence à reconstruire
alors que les Américains les
Britanniques et les FFL on à peine
dépassé Paris je veux dire on n'attend
pas on n'attend pas le 8 mai 1945 pour
commencer à reconstruire avant même le
plan Marshall dès 1944 on commence à
reconstruire et ce que dit Madame
mitrofen dans l'urgence parce que il y a
des besoins absolument immédiats même
stratégiques d'ailleurs pour pour
transporter des troupes ou comme vous le
dites tous les deux
pour pour
apporter l'aide humanitaire la plus
urgente et immédiate quitte à ce que les
l'armée russe bon barent encore et
encore et encore mais il faudra
reconstruire ces ponts justement c'est
rails il faut les remettre au temps de
fois qu'il le faudra c'est en espérant
aussi que c'est
la Fédération de Russie qui dira ouf et
et ça suffit on arrête on négocie aussi
parce que ça ça va leur coûter aussi
beaucoup d'argent démolir tout ça
Frédéric joli c'est l'heure est à la
reconstruction on vous dit ça aussi un
peu sur le terrain
l'heure il est dans le temps du Samu
c'est-à-dire le rôle des humanitaires
plus long terme on parle de
reconstruction
des rails
l'immédiateté c'est l'hiver
l'immédiateté c'est le respect du droit
international humanitaire l'immédiateté
c'est tous les états les 1806 états
partir au Conventions de Genève qui sont
engagés à ce qu'elle soit à les
respecter et aller faire respecter que
la diplomatie aussi s'exprime fortement
autour de du droit international
humanitaire il existe c'est un monument
il protège c'est le droit du plus faible
qui protège toutes les victimes dans la
guerre c'est-à-dire
les soldats blessés et les soldats
capturés ce serait aussi bien de
remettre ça au centre je veux dire de
ces dispositions et une fois de plus que
des entreprises doivent se mobiliser qui
est des initiatives et comporte une idée
de la paix est extrêmement importante
mais si on voit c'est pas pour faire du
pessimisme mais d'autres situations de
conflit gravissime parliez de l'Irak
monsieur tout à l'heure ou de la Syrie
etc on voit que le retour à la paix est
une marche lente que traumatisme sont
profonds et que parfois il faut
peut-être une bonne génération pour
commencer réellement à tourner la page
mais en tout cas nous on fait pas de
prospective on essaye de faire ce que
l'on peut sur les urgences telles
qu'elles se présentent à l'heure où nous
sommes en train de parler mais en même
temps vous avez raison parce qu'il faut
prévoir la paix parce que si on prévoit
rien le jour où la paix arrivera ça nous
prendra de cours et on ne sera pas
comment reconstruire il faut aussi il
faut préparer le court terme immédiat et
le l'urgence SAMU comme vous dites mais
également un bon état alors c'est
peut-être signe de d'un état mûr qui est
qui atteint maturité il faut prévoir
également à long terme au cas où
espérons-le la paix arrivera Oksana
l'appel elle est possible aujourd'hui
irresponsable à l'étape de la guerre
actuelle c'est assez responsable donc il
faut pas donner une fausse de Spa donc
bien sûr la paix arrive un jour mais
quand c'est pas possible de dire
maintenant strictement impossible
Pauline ou vous en parle justement vous
en parler des Ukrainiens sur place où
ils sont vraiment dans la résilience les
Ukrainiens là c'est vrai en tout cas là
pendant que pendant que j'y étais ils
sont ils pensent vraiment à là tout de
suite ce qui va se passer donc on est
vraiment plus dans le côté
comment va chauffer comment est-ce qu'on
va avoir l'électricité comment est-ce
qu'on va pouvoir communiquer avec nos
familles est-ce qu'on va avoir assez
d'eau potable donc là ils sont vraiment
plus plus là dedans et après c'est ça
reste toujours évidemment sur le côté on
reste déterminé à gagner cette guerre ça
c'est sûr et puis les gens qu'on
rencontrait avaient aussi tendance à
chaque fois à nous dire merci d'être là
merci d'être là pour nous dire et pour
montrer au monde ce qui se passe et à
chaque fois il par nous dire cela va
ukrainien Slava et ça c'est quelque
chose qui revient aussi énormément à
chaque fois et ce que je voulais dire
aussi par rapport à la reconstruction
tout à l'heure c'est que j'étais au mois
de juin aussi en Ukraine et on à
l'époque déjà les les gens qui avaient
été bombardés on avait fait d'ailleurs
un reportage sur la reconstruction qui
avait déjà démarré vous parliez des
ponts etc ça on a vu même parfois les
pompes alors on peut pas les
reconstruire tout de suite aussi bien
mais il y a des des ponts gonflables qui
sont mis en place il y a les ponts qui
sont détruits mais il y a des routes
déjà qui sont construites pour
contourner les ponts détruits et il y a
ces personnes en fait qui déjà ont pensé
à l'hiver qui allait arriver et qui
était en train déjà de reconstruire en
fait qui s'était cotisé par exemple dans
des immeubles il se cotisés pour
commencer à payer pour la reconstruction
du 3 du 3 par rapport à l'hiver qui
arrivait donc déjà au mois de juin ils
étaient déjà dans ce processus de se
dire bon on sait pas comment ça va se
passer il faut qu'on se dépêche de
réparer au moins toutes ces petites
choses parce que ça va pas se finir tout
de suite et il faut qu'on il faut qu'on
fasse le plus possible pour être au
chaud et pour au moins avoir à toi au
dessus de la tête donc on est même dans
une course contre la montre y compris
dans la reconstruction Oxana et est-ce
que vous avez eu peut-être oui dire
justement par des Ukrainiens sur place
de cette conférence d'aujourd'hui il
réagissent les Ukrainiens ce type de
concert de conférence on a vu que
est intervenu par vidéoconférence je
pense que pour les Ukrainiennes le plus
important c'est pas la conférence
annuelles mais c'est le résultat donc
c'est par exemple c'est les humanitaires
qui peuvent voir sur place c'est quelque
chose réel ou par exemple les
journalistes français qui travaillent
sur place donc c'est plus important car
même c'est le résultat par exemple c'est
tout simplement c'est générateur qui
arrive se transforment tour qui arrive
en Ukraine suite à cette conférence
ensuite il a parlé par exemple qui on
attend du gaz de l'être avec du gaz
suite aux problèmes d'énergétique tout
simplement et j'espère aussi que
l'Europe va avec l'électricité donc si
c'est l'énergie qui arrive de l'heure de
l'Europe si c'est équipement qui arrive
quelque chose assez concrète de
monétaire même les reconstructions du
pont de veau voilà c'est que ce qui est
plus important pour nous prenions
l'Europe est d'ailleurs également
débloquer un certain nombre de fonds
puisqu'ils ont trouvé finalement un
accord avec la Hongrie donc
effectivement il va y avoir aussi une
aide européenne donc voilà en tout cas
on est vraiment dans une logiqueolecope
on passe à la reconstruction en même
temps que on sait très bien que c'est
bombardements russes vont continuer donc
d'un côté on reconstruit de l'autre les
russes continuent à détruire bon et
l'hiver effectivement arrive rude mais
il tiendront le coup en fait plus là on
s'aperçoit que c'est un peu l'effet
londonien de 1940 à 1944 fait toujours
des comparaisons vous avec la deuxième
guerre mondiale
on me le reproche souvent mais moi je
suis un vieux au ciné juste après la
deuxième guerre mondiale donc c'était
encore dans les têtes de toute la
génération qui était de ceux qui étaient
plus vieux que moi
ils ont cette résilience comme vous
dites plus les Russes vont bombarder
plus ils vont malheureusement pour la
petite dame qui peut-être se sentait
même russe et probablement russophone
c'est surtout les russophones ils
souffrent le plus possible
c'est encore il y en a qui s'interdisent
de le faire parce que
bravo Poutine par exemple ils veulent
plus en tout cas on a rencontré plein de
gens qui nous disaient ah non mais nous
c'est fini on va plus parler russe on
veut exactement tendre un mot de russe
alors que alors qu'à la base ils étaient
pas contre même dire moi je suis moitié
ukrainien moitié russe ou souvenez j'ai
fait mon coming out comme ça sur votre
plateau en revenant de là-bas de la
frontière
ukraino polonaise
maintenant oui ils ont complètement
basculé alors c'est c'est on voit à quel
point c'est c'est ça a été mal conçu
aussi bien stratégiquement qui
déologiquement là ils ont perdu tous
leurs tous les soutiens qu'ils avaient
et ça va être ils seront des anti-rhus
très ukrainien aussi c'est une il y a un
an vous souvenez presque un an l'avait
je l'avais dit ici sur votre plateau
c'est il y a une nation qui est née
comme disons les États-Unis quand ils
ont commencé en tout cas la Révolution a
commencé cette conférence cette
conférence et ce 1 milliard d'euros de
dons donc promis à l'issue de cette
conférence voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire
sur la reconstruction de l'Ukraine merci
beaucoup oxalami trophée Nova d'avoir
été avec nous Pauline Pauline Godard
merci de nous avoir réservé votre
premier plateau à ce retour du crâne
merci aux hélicoptère merci Frédéric
Joly et merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivi restez avec nous sur France 24